[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
écoutez en préparant ce toc cette
chanson m'a accompagné c'est la chanson
du groupe américain twenty one paris lot
dans le titre est out vient stressé
angoissé alors dans la chanson le
chanteur dit que lorsqu'il était petit
on lui avait dit que une fois adulte
toutes ces peurs si la durée sauf qu'à
l'âge adulte tout ce qu'il ne connaît
n'est qu'un sécurité est une
personnalité fortement influencé
conséquence il le dit dont le refrain à
que j'aimerais bien revenir au bon vieux
temps de good old days
lorsque nos mères nous chanter une
berceuse pour nous endormir
mais maintenant que nous sommes
tellement stressé j'aime bien cette
chanson j'aime bien pour deux raisons
première raison c'est parce que très
banalement elle me rappelle à quel point
je suis un être profondément nostalgique
et comment ne le serait pas moi qui ai
eu la chance de connaître une belle
enfance
et vous je suis né à kinshasa au congo
et là j'ai appris à jouer au foot et des
grands du quartier de courir çà et là y
commettre toutes les bêtises quand on
puisse commettre avec des copains et
copines amos ça il vaut pour les intimes
et mando cadix hervé une habitante
oui lorsque j'entends l'expression de
good old days le bon vieux temps vous
voyez à quoi cela fait référence pour
moi je suis sûr que cela doit également
faire référence à quelque chose de très
précis dans votre esprit n'est ce pas
tenez la nostalgie comment ça marche
trois étapes premièrement un constat un
constat sur soi sur son entourage sur
nous mêmes généralement c'est un mal
être une gêne dans la chanson le constat
c'est la personnalité fortement
influençable de la deuxième étape
une comparaison comme par exemple entre
le passé et le présent est de se dire
que dans le passé les choses étaient
mieux qu'on sentait bien voir et de
l'année une conclusion mais une
conclusion liminaire spontané a priori
tout de suite au le pacd largement
préférable à l'avenir maintenant de ces
étapes on voit que la nostalgie qu'on
cite a regretté un moment du passé mais
c'est aussi quelque part souhaité son
retour à cela n'y a absolument rien de
mal car des études ont démontré que ce
souvenir se remémorer tous passés
permettait de mieux affronter l'avenir
car oui oui la nostalgie permet ou
apporte du réconfort dans des moments
parfois difficiles
la nostalgie est également une force
constructrice elle permet de se révéler
et stimule la créativité sont la
nostalgie d'ailleurs pas de joachim du
bellay le poète part de proust pas de
traîner pas de piaf et pas de
l'antimoine pilote david berliner été
professeur à l'université libre de
bruxelles a publié dans un livre récent
appel à la perte de la culture choses
comme ça perdre sa culture
dans ce livre instant il montre la
manière dont cette nostalgie envahi des
domaines aussi large que la politique le
consumérisme ou encore la culture
populaire
tenez notre culture populaire nous voyez
vous pas comment elle est bombardé de
références nostalgiques
y'a qu'a voir l'essor des friperies
vintage la multiplication des émissions
historiques à la télévision le retour
des techniques d'accouchement dites
naturelles les écomusées le tourisme
rustique le goût des vieilles pierres
des objets poli par le temps il est dire
que il s'agit d'un mouvement ample
général dans lequel hélas hélas certain
populisme vient de se nourrir
la peur du déclin et son pendant naturel
le populisme mobilise des générations
alors jeune ou moins jeune aux états
unis on l'a vu par exemple
donald trump qui exaltait l'amérique
prospère des années 20 via son slogan
mais que l'amérique redevient dans angry
littoraux ban on appelle à la grande
hongrie d'avant la première guerre
mondiale
au royaume uni des arbres sidr
s'équivalent le break 6 pts ils ont joué
ils ont le droit considère le marché
commun l'union européenne comme un cadre
trop étriqué et trompait 3 dans leurs
ambitions nationales et considère que
ses ambitions doivent aller en priorité
à la consolidation des relations que les
états unis et à la solidification des
liens qu'ils ont eue post coloniaux dans
le cadre de la commonwealth
cette fameuse faire d' influence qui
appartenait la guerre à l'empiré
britannique en france nous ne sommes pas
dire du reste de cette tendance
historiquement la france du 20e siècle a
été divisée schématiquement entre
gaullistes et pétainiste de gaulle et
pétain symbolise de porte ou en
constituent les deux porte-drapeaux
d'une france qui n'a cessé de
s'affronter depuis la révolution
bah oui étape étant considéré que le
problème de la france venait dans la
révolution 1789 et la république et donc
une fois au pouvoir il va s'évertuer à
installer par le régime contre
révolutionnaire c'est à dire
réactionnaire de gaulle a fait le chemin
inverse
pourquoi parce qu'il considérait que
cette france éternelle comme inapte les
était désormais arrimée aux idées
d'égalité le refus des privilèges la
laïcité leçon de france
pour en dire les historiens mais leçon
de vie également car de même que ces
deux hommes ont été très proches avant
que tous ne les sépare de même ces deux
hommes constituent des symboles qui ont
nous se battent la tentation de
répliques conservatrice face aux grands
périls et la volonté de dépassement de
soi
pour lui dans les multi visage de
nostalgie contemporaine il ya cette idée
que le monde du moins avant le monde les
nations notamment avait une forme de
surplus d'âme de tonus coire d'ethos
pour parler comme les grecs la nostalgie
contemporaine fulmine contre l'idée ou
du moins film in contre l'accélération
de l'évolution des choses qui seraient
dus à migrations de population notamment
à la mondialisation qui serait facteur
de d'homogénéisation et qui
perturberaient les identités locales
bien ancrée pour faire simple c'était
mieux avant de good old days
sauf qu'on y regardons un peu mieux
c'est avant ne citait pas si mieux que
ça en 1900 il y avait un nouveau film
par an en 2016
onze mille nouveaux films par an alors
pas tous de bonne qualité c'est vrai
c'est vrai en 1665 1665
il y avait que 120 articles ou travaux
scientifiques publiés par un sachant que
ce chiffre est resté constant jusqu'à
après 1900 en 2016 deux millions cinq
cent cinquante mille travaux
publications scientifiques publiées par
un dernier chiffre en 1900 considéré que
le taux d'alphabétisation était d'à peu
près 10 % en 2016 86%
pourquoi tous ces chiffres pour montrer
qu'il y à un billet à biais cognitif sur
la manière dont nous avons de traiter
l'information
j'aurais tendance à accepter plus
facilement des idées qui viennent en
quelque sorte raffermir consolider le
socle de croyance que j'ai déjà
si je considère que demain sera pire
qu'aujourd'hui
j'aurais plus facilement tendance
admettre une information qui va dans ce
sens mais même si actuellement on sait
que durant les 20 dernières années le
taux de criminalité a considérablement
baissé en occident
il y aura toujours des personnes pour
croire que le pays est au bord de
l'effondrement il à cet égard
intéressant de noter que on se souvient
très bien
en tout cas c'est bien de tout ce qui a
pu survenir lorsque nous avions 10 ans
et 30 ans sur l'échelle de vie c'est ce
qui correspond à ce que les chercheurs
en sciences de la mémoire appelle la
poste de la réminiscence la bosse de la
réminiscence en référence à la forme de
la courbe des souvenirs qui se dessine
sur le graphique de la vie d'un individu
alors se souvenir peut concerner autant
la publication d'un livre le succès
d'une chanson et que jackson tout ce que
vous voulez problème deux explications à
cela
première explication l'idée de dire que
cela correspond au développement du
cerveau durant cette période de la vigne
c'est à dire que les informations reçues
entre 10 ans et 30 ans saint-prime bien
la deuxième explication consisterait à
dire au fond que l'être humain se
souvient menez se souvient mieux de ses
première fois à prokom un peu comme
votre premier amour votre premier
premier baiser premier appart premier
échec et cetera l'idée de dire que entre
10 ans et 30 ans c'est là où
interviennent les expériences les plus
déterminantes de votre vie ceux là où
vous devenez qui vous êtes réellement
alors la question est celle de savoir
qu'est ce qui se passe lorsque cette
bosse de la réminiscence vient de se
superposer avec la prise des décisions
les plus importants dans vos vies en
particulier les décisions politiques
ceci expliquerait en tout cas selon le
docteur julia shaw spécialiste de la
mémoire
la tendance des eurosceptiques anglais
de plus de 45 ans qui ont voté lors du
référendum sur le break sites en grande
bretagne alors voici un
un graphique qui montre la manière dont
les britanniques ont voté en fonction de
leur âge de target personnes tension
l'idée de dire que la population entre
45 ans et plus de 70 ans sont des
personnes qui ont vu leur pays avant
l'entrée de la grande-bretagne dans la
communauté européenne en 73 ce sont des
gens qui ont vécu qui ont dit qu'ils ont
consentis dans leur temps leur chair la
prise d'effet des dispositifs et
européens dans leur vie et lorsqu'il
s'est agi de choisir ont décidé de
choisir livre c'est reparti à quitter
attention l'idée n'est pas de critiquer
positivement ou négativement le vote des
britanniques s'est passé à la question
l'idée de montrer que lorsqu'une
certaine nostalgie s'exprime elle est
légitime
lorsqu'elle s'exprime elle s'exprime
généralement sans nuance sans tempérance
l'individu répond ah je pars je reste
voilà et c'est paradoxal c'est que la
nostalgie n'est pas très loin du
registre de l'espérance lorsqu'elle
permet la réflexion
ah oui parce que l'individu reconnaît
que même si deux choses des choses ont
pu être perdu d'autres ont été gagnés et
peuvent l'être encore d'ailleurs on a
tendance à oublier mais le souvenir
repose sur l'oubli extraordinaire
bah oui essayez de vous souvenir que
précisément avec force détails de ce que
vous avez fait pendant vos vacances il
ya deux ans je ne sais pas à la baule ou
non le sud avec force détails vous
n'arriverez pas en revanche vous aurez
quelques idées des grandes idées autour
desquels vous allez brodé votre histoire
baril le souvenir est basée d'une part
sur l'oubli des choses telles qu'elles
se sont réellement passé et d'autre part
sur le ré écriture leur idéalisation
pouvait donc que la perte oubli est une
donnée essentielle de l'existence alors
que faire
la poétesse elizabeth bishop nous dit
qu'il faut cultiver un art de la perte
cultiver un art de l'oubli devient donc
un impératif de vie dans cette veine
cultiver de la nostalgie un peu de
nostalgie pourquoi pas mais du
déclinisme sûrement pas parce que la
peur du déclin est une vue de l'esprit
qui peut inciter quelqu'un a pensé qu'il
existerait une forme de synchronicité
simultanéité entre un peuple un
territoire et une ethnie alors même
qu'on l'a vu la perte
l'oubli est une donnée essentielle de
l'existence ce qui est certain c'est que
le monde tel qu'il a évolué j'évolue
vous évoluez nous évoluons tous et en
même temps la france avec elle mais
cette france ne peut pas se réduire à
des petites choses elle doit voir grand
elle peut pas non plus se réduire au
fétichisme des grands hommes
même si on peut avoir vous et moi pour
certains d'entre eux une certaine
nostalgie
souvenons nous d'une idée là où la
pensée féconde
là où la volonté de dépassement de soi
et vivaces le déclinisme ne prospère pas
je pense que comprendre la façon dont se
forme de pensée peut nous aider à
atténuer l'impact négatif de celle ci
surtout lorsqu'il s'agit de la prise des
décisions importantes en particulier les
décisions politiques
de quoi me souviendrai jean 2030 bas
d'abord de mettre tenu devant vous et
vous réciproquement
et de vous avoir parlé de nous tels que
nous sommes avec nos peurs ne manquent
pas notre petitesse quoi mais surtout
nos qualités c'est-à-dire nos
potentialités ne pas subir ne pas
permettre à la peur de l'effondrement de
se conjuguer avec la politique
voilà sans doute l'idée force ne se
toque rose en plus tôt nous souvenir que
nous avons quelque chose de grand
s'appelle l'avenir ce temps qui est
devant nous en commun et osons faire
quelque chose de très beau et face à cet
impératif du bo aucune nostalgie ne vaut
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]